العواصم الغربيه تسابق الزمن لنزع شوكه
الاضطرابات المستمره في كوسوفو واشنطن
باريس برلين وغيرها دخلت على الخط داعيه
اطراف النزاع لايجاد حل للازمه ووضع حد
لنزيف العنف الذي هز شماليه
[موسيقى]
اجراء انتخابات جديده بمشاركه صربيه واسعه
مقترح الى اطفاء نار غضب المحتاجين الصرب
الرافدين للانتخاب مرشحين البان لرئاسه
اربع بلديات شماليه كوسوفو
في التعاطي مع مقترح اعاده الانتخابات لكن
تحت شروط كوسوفو بوسعها اجراء انتخابات
جديده في الشمال بمشاركه الصرب ان جرت
بشكل قانوني
واضحا بخصوص هذا المقترح في هذا الخضام لم
تؤتي بعد الجهود الحثثه المبذوله لاحتواء
الاوضاع ثمارها فالتوتر لا يزال سيد
الموقف توتر دفع قوه حظر السلام التي
يقودها حلف الناتو الى استقدام تعزيزات
عسكريه من بولندا لسيطره على الاوضاع
وكان شبح توتر قد اطل من جديد في الثالث
والعشرين من شهر ابريل الماضي حين اجريت
انتخابات محليه في اربع بلديات شماليه
كوسوفو ذاتي اغلبيه صربيه انتخابات قاطعها
الصرب لتشهد مشاركه 1500 ناخب فقط من اصل
45000 مسجلين بنسبه مشاركه لم تتجاوز 4%
فتيل المواجهات اندلع بشكل فعلي في الخامس
والعشرين من شهر مايو الماضي خلال تسليم
رؤساء الالبان مناصبهم وهو ما استفز
الاقليه الصربيه
المتمركزه في هذه المنطقه هي اذا قنبله
موقوته تعلم اوروبا جيدا ان انفجارها في
الوقت الراهن قد يجر عليها ويلات صراع
جديد هي في غنى عنه وسما الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات